welcome back to science click today a
solar system the solar system is the set
of all objects which are subject to the
attraction of the Sun in the solar
system we find first and foremost a star
this is the Sun it is by far the most
massive object in the system of which it
is also the center it is around the Sun
which smaller objects gravitates then
there come four planets with a rocky
surface also known as the telluric
planets Mercury which is the smallest
and also the closest to the Sun Venus
whose very thick atmosphere creates
through a greenhouse effect an extremely
high surface temperature reaching almost
500 degrees Celsius earth the largest of
the rocky planets we find on its surface
liquid water and complex living
organisms it also possesses a satellite
the moon which orbits around it finally
comes mass the telluric planet furthest
away from the Sun Mars possesses two
small moons Phobos and Deimos behind
Mars we find the large asteroid belt it
is composed of hundreds of thousands of
small rocky debris these asteroids can
sometimes leave their orbits and reach
earth by chance as meteorites behind the
asteroid belt come for gaseous planets
gaseous planets like a solid surface
they are enormous spheres of gas held
together around very dense nucleus by
gravitational pull the first gaseous
planet is Jupiter it is the largest of
all planets in the solar system on its
surface we find some extremely violent
storms and powerful winds since Jupiter
is so massive its gravitational pull is
powerful and it possesses over 60 moons
which orbit around it such as Europa or
Ganymede next comes Saturn slightly
smaller and surrounded by a number of
concentric rings these rings are made up
of rocky debris and ice which orbit
around the planet
Saturn also possesses over 60 moons such
as Titan or Enceladus it is not the only
planet to have rings around it
however Saturn's rings are much more
visible than those of any other planets
behind Saturn lies Uranus and then comes
Neptune these two gaseous planets are
much smaller than the previous ones
despite still being much larger than
Earth they also possess a few rings
which are very hard to make out
Uranus possesses around 30 moons while
Neptune the smallest of the gaseous
planets has around 20 the rocky planets
and the gaseous planets are not alone in
the solar system there is also a number
of dwarf planets which is smaller than
regular ones but larger than mere
asteroids amongst warf planets we find
series for example the largest object in
the asteroid belt or Pluto which
possesses a number of moons like Charon
Nick's or Kerberos further out is
another asteroid belt known as kuipers
belts finally behind Kuiper belt comes a
multitude of small objects such as
comets which orbit around the Sun from
very far out this is what we call the
Oort cloud although the solar system is
better known than ever it remains a
matter of controversy where to place its
limits the most common definition places
the end of the solar system just behind
the Oort cloud because at this distance
the gravitational pull from the Sun is
almost too weak to be felt in all cases
the solar system cannot be reduced to
the a planets we know it is an immense
system which is filled with many objects
we have yet to discover to have a better
understanding of scale the width of the
solar system is at least a hundred
thousand times greater than the distance
that separates the Earth from the Sun
and yet our star is only one among
billions there exist in the universe an
incredible variety of stellar systems
with planets that are still completely
unknown and perhaps even other
life-forms different from the ones found
on earth
[Music]